okay I have a big update for you today
about a truly incredible story that I
brought to you yesterday let me catch
you up Tuesday night we did a live
commentary stream of the Democratic
presidential debate we did it on our
twitch platform we are on all sorts of
different platforms we tend to do the
live debate coverage on twitch at twitch
TV slash David Pakman about halfway
through that debate our stream was shut
down along with the streams of numerous
other left-wing streamers basically at
the same time almost at the exact same
time now because the debate was on CBS
the assumption was CBS shut down these
debate streams but very quickly
something didn't seem quite right and we
started to get emails that said that the
claimant was not CBS it was instead a
company called praxis political legal we
did an investigation and immediately we
found that the email address listed as
the contact email for these claims by
Praxis political legal didn't exist and
when I emailed them the email instantly
bounced back we found that the company
had almost no online presence whatsoever
merely a single-page website on one of
those website builders called card with
two R's CA RR D sort of like your
website being political practices
political dot blog spot.com that's the
equivalent of what they had and it
seemed weird that's what we knew as of
yesterday either
CBS hired a very shadowy company with
almost no presence to file mask
copyright claims against left-wing
streamers or this was all a fraud and
this company was claiming to represent
CBS when they did not now either way the
effect on us was disastrous it put us at
risk of a permanent ban from twitch so I
immediately contacted a lawyer contacted
twitch his legal department I pointed
out there's a lot of red flags here I
was notified late yesterday towards the
end of the day yesterday that twitch his
legal investigation determined the
copyright strikes were
bogus these scammers tricked twitch into
believing that they represented CBS they
did not and they successfully got I
don't know the number a whole bunch of
left-wing streamers shut down a number
of articles have been written about this
vice covered it and used week covered it
the verge covered it there's a whole
bunch of different articles about it now
additionally while this investigation
was going on yesterday the website for
praxis political legal disappeared
altogether from the internet just
removed very very odd so the right thing
was done here in the sense that they
determined the strikes were bogus they
weren't from someone actually
representing CBS they removed the strike
from our account our account on twitch
has been reinstated that's the good news
the bad news is and this is not getting
enough attention the bad news is the
broken dysfunctional system that exists
on both YouTube and twitch for dealing
with copyright issues because both
YouTube and twitch have a system where
anybody claiming that their copyright is
being violated can almost instantly have
live streams and videos taken down and
then it becomes the responsibility of
the publisher me us to prove that either
the claim was fraudulent that we were
authorized because we have a license or
fair use or whatever to broadcast or
publish that content it's sort of ban
now ask questions later and this can
take 24 hours it could take 48 hours it
can take 30 days it can sometimes take
months because that is how long YouTube
keeps copyright strikes on until they
eventually fall off on twitch they never
fall off although there's rumors that
they're looking at changing that so the
right outcome ultimately prevailed here
but it's a broken system the system you
know I was thinking about Trump and the
founding fathers they hear me out the
founding fathers set up checks and
balances and they never imagined that a
president would come in and simply
ignore the checks and balances which
Donald Trump has
and then what happens it turns out
nothing happens there have been no
consequences to Donald Trump for
flouting norms and checks and balances
the creators of YouTube and twitch may
never have imagined that bad faith
fraudulent actors would show up while an
important event for our democracy is
taking place a presidential debate and
file a massive number of bogus copyright
claims effectively shutting down endless
of the the the viewership for thousands
and tens of thousands of people that
were watching these streams so the
system has to be changed they should
have to show that their copyright is
being violated they must have to prove
that they are actually authorized
representatives of the copyright holder
because otherwise even though in this
one instance it was quote solved the
same thing will happen either next week
or next month or whenever we're covering
events important to our democracy and it
will continue to jeopardize the
livelihood of independent media creators
like us ban first ask questions later
which is employed by YouTube it's
employed by twitch it doesn't work it
doesn't work and if anything what we've
learned from this is okay if everybody
gets together and spends almost 24
consecutive hours researching and doing
our own investigations and hiring our
own lawyers we can get one strike
reversed but this doesn't change the
system that is so acutely broken and
that's what we need to focus on one way
or the other I don't know how to do it
one of our sponsors is privacy calm
they're giving you $5.00 when you sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy calm slash Pakman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click
the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them you can delete them any
time you want so when you do this it
means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
I love using free trials because I know
I won't be charged when the trial is
over if I use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private by not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman